When you're a hulk trouble's gonna find
you this thursday weird unexpected trouble
let's do this seahawk culture is
a total snack oh yeah abomination
namaste walk the sorceress supreme and madison
two ends one why but it's not where you think
just remember whose show this actually is
she-hulk is streaming on disney plus this thursday
Welcome back everyone this will be my new she-hulk
trailer video and early reviews breakdown there's
a whole bunch of easter eggs obviously in a bunch
of details that they revealed about the future of
the series and what's going on with avengers
5 kang dynasty like how this all ties in with
everything else like everyone's obviously talking
about daredevil coming back again but this is just
the tip of the iceberg if you're brand new to the
channel i'll be doing videos for all the episodes
they literally start this week so i will be
posting my episode one video after they release it
be sure to subscribe to get all those we're doing
a marvel giveaway for disney plus memberships all
you have to do to enter is be a subscriber and
let me know what you want them to do with she-hulk
during avengers 5. but speaking of avengers 5 mark
ruffalo was actually recently talking about how
she hulk would be in avengers 5 like he was just
confirming like oh yeah she's going to be in kang
dynasty if you didn't already assume that like
for the most part the vast majority of all the new
characters that they've introduced in marvel phase
4 like the brand new ones will have some kind of
role in avengers 5 like not every character is
going to be as big as the others or get as much
screen time and that doesn't mean that every
brand new character is going to be like a core
avengers team member because it's kind of like
an avengers end game situation where you have a
movie with a core group of avengers and then many
many other characters helping out in some way like
even though captain america does the biggest
avengers assemble that you've ever seen with
them all flying at thanos's army at the same time
that doesn't mean that all these other hundreds
and hundreds of people can also call themselves
avengers most of the early reviews are pretty
hype on this series just the way that they use the
character in the mcu in like the different tone
of this series from the other marvel series like
they're trying to make it feel like a completely
different thing inside the mcu in the way that
one division felt very different from falcon
and winter soldier felt very different from moon
knight because in the comics jennifer walters is a
lawyer by day like she continues to be a lawyer
for superheroes but also a superhero by night
they basically built this series to feel like
a half hour legal comedy type of show that sort
of spins up into big avengers level stuff by the
end they actually said that they had to move the
order of some of the episodes around like largely
the episodes are what they originally conceived
them to be there were only a couple characters
that kevin feige would not let them use like
spider-man i'll explain why in a second because
practically it actually makes a lot of sense why
you can't use spider-man in a series like this
which is mostly like a courtroom drama with a
bunch of superhero stuff happening on the side
to make another daredevil reference there were
so many daredevil theories about how he was going
to help spider-man get out of all of his problems
with mysterio the biggest reason why they couldn't
use spider-man is mostly just because of what they
just did with the spell on spider-man no way home
and what they're doing in all the episodes having
them go through all these trials in court like
they would have actually had to use spider-man
in court in trials and it would have just
gotten way too weird logically trying to explain
how they can maintain the effects of the spell
in his secret identity while he's still in court
testifying like he would have had to keep his mask
on inside all these trials in the court system
at least in the united states would not have
allowed him to do that like he would have had to
unmask himself again so it would have completely
taken back all the stuff that they did during
spiderman no way home so logically it just did
not make sense to put him in all these episodes
the difference with the character like daredevil
is that like you have everybody not understanding
that matt murdock really is daredevil but during
daredevil season 3 that's kind of what kingpin
wanted to do like he wanted to drag his name
through the mud so he had bull's-eye dress up in
the daredevil costume doing all these terrible
things pretending to be daredevil the way they
kind of took that back at the end of the finale
is that daredevil proved that it wasn't him in the
costume like no this is somebody else pretending
to be daredevil doing all these terrible things
so we can continue working as a lawyer by day
as matt murdock and then at night as daredevil
so like at least at the beginning of the series
she-hulk would not know that matt murdock is
daredevil but one of the big changes they said
they had to make to the series early on is when
they were cutting things together they had to
reorder some of the episodes and events just so
that they were easier to understand for non-comic
book readers originally they were using a more
moon knight method to reveal her full backstory
like it takes you a couple episodes before you
learn what's really going on on moon night they
were originally going to start the she-hulk series
in a similar way like where you just start with
her already being she-hulk being a lawyer but it
seems like they just felt like her introduction
during that version was a little too jarring for
non-comic book readers like if you've ever read
any marvel comics you probably already understand
who she hook is what's going on with the character
and how she's lawyer by day superhero by night
like daredevil but apparently for non-comic
book readers apparently it was just too much too
confusing so they used a more linear path to show
you her backstory who she is what her personality
is what her relationship with bruce banner hulk is
in how their cousins and then show you her getting
the powers being trained by hulk and then going
back to her life where you pick up with her just
trying to continue on with her normal life as if
nothing has changed except she's like this almost
seven feet tall green rage monster now and her
law firm now has her just specifically working
on superhero cases like the abominations case
for instance and during the trailers you hear
her make all the jokes about being on the avengers
how she doesn't want to have anything to do with
that lifestyle but the hulk warns her that it's
not her choice like now that she has these powers
there'll be larger earth-shattering consequences
eventually the way they plotted the stakes of the
series like overall is they actually start out
with it being a little bit more mundane and then
spin up to avengers level problems i guess they
kind of did the same thing with moon knight too
mooney was only six episodes and this is nine
episodes like you start out with a more indiana
jones type quest in moon night where they're
trying to get the scarab then you learn about
them trying to bring back omit then finally by the
end of the episode amit finally does come back and
start sucking out everyone's souls and it becomes
this huge world ending problem all of a sudden
but like through all the episodes you'll see all
the cameo scenes wong for instance big avengers
level cameo then we'll start to explain why she
gets involved with the new avengers team heading
into avengers 5. like it'll start with funnier
stuff like wong has a problem he needs to sue
this other magician character like you see him at
all these fight scenes here then later eventually
he'll bring her onto the team the other big
connection to the actual avengers into the
thunderbolt series 2 on the side is the sokovia
accords they said that during the series because
this is like a legal base series she's a lawyer
by day just like daredevil the sokovia accords are
basically like this giant legal document they will
address the terms of the actual sokovia cores and
what happened to them after avengers end game so
that'll just be another way that she gets involved
with avengers level stuff this new avengers team
in avengers 5. the sokovia accords were basically
a tool that thunderbolt ross used to try and
control the avengers like he was trying to tell
them what to do obviously that didn't work out
for him i think ultimately that will just build
up to them eventually forming the thunderbolts
team like okay you're an avengers team that i
can control sort of like a dark avengers but
they'll just call it the thunderbolts team
in the comics thunderbolts and dark avengers are
two like completely different concepts but i think
in the mcu they'll just try to combine those ideas
i've also already talked about how jennifer walter
she-hulk is going to be representing abomination
trying to get him out of prison for all the crazy
stuff that he's done since incredible hulk and how
that's eventually going to lead to val recruiting
him for the thunderbolts team but like he's
just part of it during the she-hulk trailers
you see a lot of titania footage of her going at
she-hulk just being completely off the rails crazy
the actress who plays titania started talking
a lot about her being in the thunderbolts movie
i think kevin feige has an idea of what the
thunderbolts roster is going to be but a lot
of that could change on the way because it's going
to be a while before they start filming the movie
the other really cool thing that they've revealed
is that there's going to be post credit scenes
after every single she-hulk episode they'll be a
little bit different obviously and the end credits
themselves like the actual credits scenes where
the credits roll are supposed to be fairly epic
with a bunch of extra easter eggs kind of like
the loki series where there were just a bunch of
extra details and easter eggs in the background
while the actual credits were playing they kind
of did that a little bit during moon night but not
quite as much as they did during the loki series
so there will be a lot of pausing a lot of zooming
and enhancing on the actual credits themselves
not just the post-credits scenes but the episode
one post-credit scene like the very first one is
supposed to be fairly epic one of the other funny
things that tatiana maslany was talking about
was she-hulk eventually representing scarlet
witch in court like as if the people of earth
or the people of west view would sue her for
trapping them in west view for an entire week
kind of torturing them she also referenced about
all the crazy stuff that scarlet witch was doing
during doctor strange shoot like scarlet witch has
been through a lot she really needs some help she
needs someone to defend her and if it wasn't clear
at the end of doctor strange too scarlet witch is
still alive like you just see some rubble from the
temple collapse on her and then that big burst of
chaos magic was basically like a protective
barrier to protect her in a bubble literally
so she's still around it's just marvel doesn't
want to reveal what's happening with her currently
until they ready to bring her back before avengers
5. because of the way her powers work she'll
probably be critical during avengers 5 and then
avengers 6 secret wars tatiana maslany was also
telling jokes about having scenes with deadpool
because they both break the fourth wall but in the
comics i believe deadpool is meant to be from the
same town that tatiana maslany is from in canada
in real life so she was joking about both
of them in character talking to each other
breaking the fourth wall going back between the
characters talking to each other and the actors
themselves talking to each other as if they
were not the characters like how meta can you
actually get when you have a scene with deadpool
and another character that just spends all the
time breaking the fourth wall that's also one
of the beauties of deadpool movies is that they
don't have to make sense because deadpool himself
is a character who is not supposed to make sense
so you can get away with pretty much any type
of reference or any type of joke that you want
i am curious to see though if when we get to
avengers 5 because deadpool is also probably
going to be in that if he or she hulk will break
the fourth ball in an actual avengers movie
because we haven't seen that yet real big reminder
though my full she-hulk episode 1 video is going
to post thursday after they release it they're
nine episodes total so if you have any special
requests or big questions just write them below in
the comments and i'll include those in my videos
congratulations crave trance you're the giveaway
winner from my last big marvel video please email
me on the about page of my channel so i can get
your contact details everyone click here for
my brand new loki season 2 first look video and
everyone click here for all my she-hulk episode
videos thank you so much for watching everyone
stay safe and i'll see you guys in the next one!